hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers for work
can't come soon enough with the absence
of even a title or a trailer forcing
nerds like us to re-watch The Avengers
infinity war little clues and pick apart
every little statement from the cast and
crew for possible reveals and there is
now a new theory that suggests
characters like hella Loki and the
ancient one even could return and
ventures forth and how Thor rock and
Valkyrie could help with that
resurrection it's all started with one
of my favorite sources of information
Mark Ruffalo Bruce Banner may be always
angry but Rebelo is always gossin
including when he's spoiled the ending
of infinity war nearly a year before the
movie came out something Don Cheadle
roadie recently recalled with Jimmy
Kimmel be wait till you see this next
one everybody - not everybody know that
can we rewind that part nice this is Ben
we can't get ice cream looking back on
this Cheadle said this - Kimmel is he
going to be allowed to do press for
anything no he's done Marvel films for
any movie because he might talk about a
Marvel movie so he's just done yeah
right the thing is she don't might not
be joking here because back in November
Ruffalo did an interview for the I am
Rapoport podcast and when asked about
his favorite actors to work with Ruffalo
said this tilda swinton I just worked
with which was amazing she's a machines
cranking unbelievably good and present
and and playful and sweet and funny um a
little bit of Cate Blanchet another
amazing actress thanks for hello the
fact that he mentions them back-to-back
suggests that it could be the same
project so the ancient one and helis
seem like the obvious roles he was
referring to there by saying this Revell
OLED fans on reddit to look at some set
photos and travel schedules of the cast
and crew and by the way if this is
getting too spoilery for you I get it
but you know you've come this far and
these are really just best guesses
anyway so let's just keep digging all
right let's read a theory states that
Avengers 4 could journey into hell no
not the hgl hell that you're going to
because of your search history single l
health
former residents of hella goddess of
death the police she escaped from in
thor ragnarok remember characters like
hella and loki are gods it wouldn't be
too far out of the question to assume
that rather than just dying the way
normal humans do their spirits are
transferred to an afterlife dimension
for the Asgardian heroes typically that
afterlife would be Valhalla but you know
since Asgard was destroyed at the end of
Ragnarok perhaps the only place for
these souls to go would be hell hello
could have returned there after losing
to search her and Loki could be in hell
as well according to lore it would
actually be the function of the Valkyrie
leading the Valkyrie or to go into hell
and guide the souls of great warriors to
Valhalla so maybe we can expect to see
this kind of rescue mission for Loki and
Avengers for now Avengers 3 and 4 shot a
lot of their scenes at the same time and
set photos showed the crew shooting the
scene at Durham Cathedral in England
that was the same location from age of
Ultron remember when Thor was having his
dream now while these scenes were being
shot reportedly in the area were spotted
Chris Hemsworth Tessa Thompson Tom
Hiddleston Cate Blanchet and a stand-in
prop of Rocket Raccoon that they used
for camera angles now remember in age of
Ultron Thor uses the water of sites to
try to remember that dream that Scarlet
Witch induced in his mind that dream
showed Heimdall giving some very
interesting warnings to Thor under your
eyes oh they see everything they see you
leading us to hell yeah dad can you not
see him go a destroyer Odinson see where
your power leads perhaps the fact that
Avengers force seems to be returning to
this Durham Cathedral location means
that four could experience a similar
trip to an afterlife with his fellow
Asgardians dead in hell he could find
his sister the goddess of death and
arrange some kind of bargain with her to
resurrect their brother Loki yes I know
this is the exact opposite of what Dan
owes to shirt us after he killed Loki in
infinity war arose erections this time
there could be all kinds of unforeseen
Asgardian magic that Thanos doesn't
truly understand like it definitely
seemed confused by how the Bifrost
worked and Stormbreaker was the one
weapon that could hurt him even when he
had all six Infinity stones
so just because Thanos said no
resurrections doesn't mean he's
objectively right forever anyway
me it's also super interesting to hear
that Tilda Swinton might return is the
ancient one remember in her death scene
of Doctor Strange she explained that she
could never foresee beyond the moment of
her death and that time as a whole is
relative you don't get to choose our
time death is what gives life meaning to
know your days are numbered your time is
short
we know that in other dimensions across
the MCU time itself doesn't work exactly
the same way in the Dark Dimension
Doctor Strange uses time as a weapon
against her mama and when it comes to
the quantum realm Hank Pym described
time as irrelevant and Janet Van Dyne
mentioned the existence of time vortexes
down there so perhaps hell is another
realm where times sort of span still and
maybe it's part of some broader
otherworldly dimension that includes all
these things along with the quantum
realm where all of our fallen characters
could now exist in including the ancient
one but also all the heroes that we saw
fade away after Thanos has snapped and a
return to the afterlife that Thor's
sister was banished to could be one way
that Thor begins the rescue of the souls
that we lost but of course you don't
leave you guys with should Loki be
resurrected like do you feel his story
arc was complete and Infinity Ward or
were you left feeling unsatisfied with
his death comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at ei vas for other projects I
got in store for you guys like this
video share it around subscribe to new
rockstars to be there every time Mark
Ruffalo says something that he really
should also let's find you and we're so
grateful for
[Music]